is your most accurate weather now
forecast this is a great view from our
camera
on top of the bank of america building
that's on the near northwest at rainbow
in the 95 you see the
95 down there we've had some virga and
we have had some sprinkles the official
temperature at 90.
two big things with the weather today
we're not going to hit triple digits
and we've already had and we'll continue
to have scattered
off and on sprinkles we're not talking
about big time storms
or major accumulation in fact when we
say no triple digits
the temperature probably won't even
change a whole lot it may stay
in the low to the mid 90s all day along
the west side of town you're in the 80s
hanging on to the low 90s for downtown
and in henderson
elsewhere with nevada and beyond death
valley you're at 97.
laughlin near 90. good morning kingman
with an 80.
so we're going for only 95 today and our
current temperature is the low so you
see not a whole lot of movement there
normally we'd be at 102. let's go ahead
and show you the latest radar pictures
looks like you might be picking up some
showers now on the 215 beltway from
charleston
up to the northern 215 build where
curves around there at walapai
and it's going to continue that way as
these storms move from the south to the
north they're moving very quickly we're
not anticipating
major accumulation and here's that tweet
from the weather service
we can confirm that it does rain in las
vegas at 4 am
somebody came back from outside with a
wet shirt
at the national weather service
indicating that
it either did rain or they've got a poor
sprinkler system out there
checking in on your family and friends
big time storms moving out of iowa
through northern illinois
and our eight day forecast well the
storms definitely sticking around today
no triple digits tomorrow right back to
100 though on friday and that begins a
climb back towards 110
on monday